gomez life welcome back to the wolf
among us
episode 2 you're excited I'm excited
let's do this
before we begin however I do want to
warn for spoilers so if you haven't
checked the game out yourself go ahead
and check the link in the description
and you can play it yourself
it should be out on Steam today there's
supposed to be a strip club that's all I
know that's all I need to know baby I'm
not gonna lie I'm I'm pretty sick I know
a lot of your good bros are saying he's
sick but still so handsome - top it stop
it most of you probably saying oh you
shouldn't be recording but don't worry I
promise after this I'm gonna go to bed
so don't don't don't be like okay yeah
really
the game just came out I'm not gonna let
a freaking cold stand in my way okay
I've been excited for this railroad
something big thing before we completely
tears up the place whoa whoa whoa hey
hey you've got something on your face
[ __ ] are you talking about you stupid Oh
and that's [ __ ] up don't interrupt me
miss no you asked me a question don't
change the subject you are complete for
this unpleasantness miss no no I D he's
dumb things are worse off than they've
ever been
well that's not true right we've had it
worse but not by much
I can't believe what happened in the
last one I mean can we just talk about
that for me so anyway I know a lot of
viewers are very excited for Walking
Dead what what is really awesome about
tell time is how often they released
these episodes so one month we're gonna
get a wolf among us episode and one
month they want that that we're gonna
get a Walking Dead episode oh yeah I
can't believe this happened man
that's [ __ ] up man Oh [ __ ] Oh suck
it give I really liked her
coke then it has to be if you just
cooperate and answer the questions you
can go home maybe get some sleep maybe I
don't want to go how are you feeling I
know it's been a long night for you you
look like you could use some rest
I need to find the killer I'll be better
when I find who did this which I can't
do while sitting in here we all want the
same thing here big B look I know what
you must be going through really I do
yeah we I know you're they [ __ ]
what um are you okay okay you don't look
so good detective Brannigan
I'm detective Brannigan uh yeah I know I
just said that
is there something it's a crap please
okay oh not don't let her die - come on
don't let her die - come on you need to
stop hanging around women man god damn
hi I even like her Oh God what's up we
have to go now what did he do to her did
you do to her she'll be fine
it's just a memory wipe spell very
expensive but it works the whole station
will forget the last 24 hours
and everything they saw at The Woodlands
why is that good well hurry up
huh I think he's the perpetrator
I'd be too obvious I guess oh that's sad
man sad sad man
frickin love the style of this game man
it's so cool
mmmm well this doesn't change anything
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna play the big
bad wolf part okay this doesn't change
anything
fine we we found Tweedledee chained up
to a post that was your doing correct
yeah well I don't know why you detained
him he was at the trip tracking snow was
left at The Woodlands so he couldn't
possibly be involved in this mayhem hmm
what about the other one yeah what about
his brother
currently interrogating him there's two
of them D and um they've been snooping
around every crime scene I've looked at
that doesn't mean they're necessarily
involved in the murders well they're
definitely a suspect
I know what you're thinking Big B D it's
been one full night in a slice of
morning
and I already miss her too ah she seems
so nice like I can't believe two of that
what you thought would be they never get
more main character girls right now it
to be snow I've never been good with
these sorts of things
I just can't believe this is really
happening
yeah it's hard man yeah it's hard
our stories used to be so simple we had
a beginning middle and an end
and now there's an after his awful city
everything's gotten so confused
did she give any indication to what she
was thinking you saw her last night I
don't know why but I'd like to know that
she was I guess fine I suppose she
wanted to change things you could come
off as callous sometimes but she wasn't
really she said that she wanted to
change things make it easier for fables
to get help when they need it
I don't know what else to say Digby we
have to have to put an end to this well
no [ __ ] man
it's been two murders in this many days
we don't unearth our culprit and soon
there will likely be another on our
doorstep tonight I'll get it done that's
actually true
please baby for Miss white I got it oh
ho ho
SAS SAS has so much sass I don't hope
there will be more about that buting the
Beast know whatever that's not a very
good answer is it come on what is this
tell me what I want to know it will make
things a lot less painful for you yeah
Bluebeard theory Oh were you planning on
using that I just thought you really
liked rubbing your little sword you
think you're doing
hello Ichabod sheriff Bluebeard
and it's blow me chatting with our new
friend Nathan I supposed to wait for us
to get back I told you if you want to be
involved you will do things my way
no violence whatever you say Chabad
kinda looks like a gay Gordon Freeman
hello Big B I want answers dee oh goody
I thought you wanted questions and I was
having so much trouble thinking of any
good one
hey don't thank me I settled on how's
your hand
Snow White is dead look I didn't kill
anyone and I'm supposed to just believe
you earth cannot query with me when it
happened dummy I know you have a [ __ ]
tire or you D sounds like a personal
problem this is ridiculous okay what she
had him work he's got more experience
with these kinds of I really want to
know what he was doing override toads
looking for a change of scene that's
[ __ ] thought am i moving had to take
a look around first course
Tyrel Buena
all right Dee let's get to know each
other
all right Shh this is getting old very
what is it now big B why were your
turtle again why were you a toads having
a cup of tea
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] ooh so this is how it's gonna be I
thought you catch on the first time only
what you were doing at toads place I
can't tell you and pushing me around
isn't gonna change that my brother and I
work hard and we keep our mouths shut
that's the deal so I got him talking huh
I forgot about your brother doc right
appropriate there was your brother last
night yeah accusing him of something
why shouldn't I think he didn't do it if
that's what you're getting at he didn't
kill her
then who did no [ __ ] right to keep me
here you have no evidence give me my
stuff and let me go what did you find on
her oh uh nothing no consequence really
I'll see about that I'll be taking that
money and cigar thank you it's that I
have it under you baby you give up what
he knows
DS whiskey DS cash or DS gar hmm you're
a mess big be shut out you shut the [ __ ]
up okay I don't really know let's go for
the money you always carry this much
cash I don't like backs so what
I don't need its [ __ ] money
so where's your brother
look might I'd like to help I would but
I can't tell you where he is
last time I saw him we split up and I
went to find faith I Jerry is now you
wanted to find a fair anybody you were
looking for faith yeah I went to her
apartment that's no secret you saw me
Sybilla Deus you said you were trying to
find something all right Dean what did
you want from faith sorry I can't help
you I'm not saying any more about well
you are saying if you say you got a say
be you'll [ __ ] pay for this me what
are you doing getting answers I told you
to keep yourself under control let me
handle this yeah come on there big nose
out of it what did you want from faith I
didn't want [ __ ] from that little thief
what trouble than she's worth the house
that mean the same about you
oh yeah what did she steal me and see
how much trouble I earn what did she
steal must have been valuable I don't
know
was just some dumb thing my boss was
after haha your boss so let's talk about
your boss then mmm-hmm
you spilled the juice it's clear you're
just following orders so who's calling
the shots no I'm [ __ ] done
we're not done there's nothing wrong
with easing up a little he's more likely
to talk that way and hop yeah some
Scotch you just carry this around it
ain't illegal is it let's offer him a
drink you know like I but take out my
[ __ ] face
and now you wanna be best friends no
[ __ ] one you're out of your mind just
cooperate as you cooperate I'll be nice
this is all up to you unbelievable
I couldn't hurt I guess yeah [ __ ]
flame ball why don't you just tell me
who you're working for
look you're not a bad guy
despite what Beauty says about you at
least you know a total bastard anyway
but I just can't give you that
information what is beauty no no wait
when they associate with a scumbag like
you yeah what's wrong with me you're
telling me I ain't pretty enough
let him talk yeah we're real close the
hell is that supposed to be a murder
investigation
but you're treating this guy like a
[ __ ] houseguest no beard really we're
making progress before what is this
patty-cake
[ __ ] God Android is dead one of us and
you're going to let this ignorant [ __ ]
walk out of here in one piece
out of my way does it look like oh that
was [ __ ] what do you think you're doing
teaching him a lesson now pay attention
a van right now Buick
and yourself stop top what the only I
can hit my [ __ ] I don't make me fight
you man we're just gonna lose baby ah
come on
cuz this no no
what they did a game crash or some [ __ ]
oh that's one hell of a [ __ ] injure
goddamn goddamn got my nipple hole juice
up I was gonna say my whatever okay you
weren't supposed to know that
[ __ ] yeah this is why I love the wolf
among us or telltale games there this
[ __ ] [ __ ] man all right
that's sickening him in how the hell
would she come back
was it an evolution I don't know what
goes in this high press I'm gonna have
to cut the first one a little bit short
cause I'm like I'm I don't want to be
like sick for the entire episode so
hopefully I'm better tomorrow and we can
continue I'm sorry I'm sorry for not
being a hundred percent or whatever yeah
I'll be better don't worry hope you
realize how excited as I am for more
episodes of wolf among this remember to
get the game out yourself if you're
interested there's really nothing like
playing these games yourself and it's
good to support a developers I think
they're really cool so but regardless
leave a like if you enjoy watching and
want to support this series like as
always I really appreciated bros your
bros are the coolest I just love that I
can do this for you it's the best and
it's all thanks to your support so I
really do appreciate it
whoever you are out there thank you
here's the brofist for you stay awesome